más de un año de pandemia profundiza los
retos de la educación a nivel global así
lo señalan varios de los participantes
de la cumbre mundial de educación
organizada por reino unido y kenia
guardáns algunos niños han estado fuera
de la escuela durante más de nueve meses
aumentando hacia el riesgo de que
abandonen su educación lo que pone en
riesgo sus posibilidades de empleo
futuro y su salud
el evento pretende recaudar fondos con
el objetivo de acercarse a cumplir con
el derecho de una educación inclusiva
gratuita y de calidad a nivel global un
niño cuya madre sabe leer tiene un 50
por ciento más de probabilidades de
vivir más allá de los 5 años un 50 por
ciento más de probabilidades de estar
vacunado y el doble de probabilidades de
asistir a la escuela nuestra causa hoy
empodera a las niñas y mujeres pero
también ayuda a familias comunidades y
naciones enteras sin embargo muchas
poblaciones siguen excluidas este es el
caso de las niñas en el mundo según
calcula la unesco 15 millones de niñas
en edad de asistir a primaria nunca lo
harán 9 millones de estas se encuentran
en áfrica subshariana y sólo 85 niñas
por cada 100 niños tienen acceso a ese
derecho casi 130 millones de niñas no
iban a la escuela antes de que comenzara
la pandemia de kobe 19 ahora son 20
millones más que corren el riesgo de
abandonar la escuela a causa de esta la
reunión deja en claro que las
desigualdades mundiales amplificadas por
el coi 19 no se pueden solventar si no
se asegura el acceso a la educación de
los niños en todo el mundo